i'd like to thank senator rick scott the
ranking member of the subcommittee for
agreeing to work with me in a bipartisan
way
on the critical issues that are so
important to workers
businesses and families in both of our
states
and across the country and i look
forward to a productive
partnership i'd also like to thank chair
cantwell and ranking member wicker for
their tremendous leadership
and for agreeing to establish this
crucial subcommittee
at a time when travel tourism and
hospitality
they need more support than ever before
travel and tourism related industries
drive job creation and economic growth
in states across america especially in
nevada
where these industries and the workers
to employ are absolutely essential
to our state's prosperity from the
excitement and energy of the las vegas
strip
the exquisite outdoor recreation
opportunities at lake tahoe
to the magnificent engineering feat
that is the hoover dam and the vast and
pristine
public lands throughout our state people
love
to visit nevada prior to the pandemic in
2019 about 55 million people
visited the silver state which was a
record-setting figure
in the las vegas area alone direct
visitor spending
reached almost 37 billion
directly directly supported more than
242
000 workers in the tourism leisure and
hospitality industries
jobs in those sectors account for about
nine percent
of all u.s jobs a major slice of the
nation's economy
and in nevada they employ about a
quarter of our workforce
with tourism as our lifeblood this
pandemic has hit nevada particularly
hard
it brought our travel and tourism having
economy screeching to a halt and
decimated the jobs that these industries
support
in april 2020 the unemployment rate in
nevada was the highest in our state's
history
and the worst in the nation it
skyrocketed to almost
30 percent i want to repeat that 30
percent
unemployment they were unemployed
through no fault of their own
it was all because of the covet 19
pandemic
and that contributed to the worst
economic downturn in the tourism
industry
we have ever experienced in my state of
nevada
through ppp loans the employee retention
tax credit direct aid to restaurants and
live entertainment
and unemployment relief congress has
worked to support
tourism businesses and workers during
this difficult period
but far more needs to be done now it's
time to bring this critical industry
back to its thriving pre-pandemic
economic
status i intend to use this subcommittee
to find bipartisan pathways
and solutions to do just that we're
going to get americans and the world
traveling again today's inaugural
hearing
titled the state of travel and tourism
during covid will examine the economic
impacts of the coven 19 pandemic on the
travel
and tourism industry with a particular
focus
on hotels conventions and the broader
hospitality industry
we'll discuss regional impacts of the
pandemic on tourism-heavy economies
like nevada's and florida's and those
communities disproportionately affected
by coven 19's resulting
economic downturn here today both
virtually and in person we have a panel
of
wonderful witnesses to share their
expertise provide insight
and recommendations and take questions
from members of the subcommittee
we will hear from witnesses representing
the las vegas convention and visitors
authority
mgm resorts international u.s travel
association
the florida restaurant and lodging
association
from this hearing i hope the
subcommittee will gain a robust
understanding of the current needs of
our nation's travel and tourism industry
so that we can craft the most effective
and targeted solutions to revive our
economy
and support the travel and tourism
workforce
travel and tourism industry has many
components so while the focus of today
this primary hotel is primarily hotels
conventions
and the broader hospitality industry
from restaurants to casinos
ranking member scott and i will ensure
this top committee
hears from key stakeholders across the
board
over the next few months we'll hear from
our airports and others about the
pandemic's
impacts on international travel we'll
examine the outdoor recreation economy
and ecotourism we'll raise the voices of
small businesses
hospitality workers and the live
entertainment workforce
and will chart a path towards the future
thank you all again for being here today
i look forward to hearing each of you
share your experiences
and expertise with us turn it over to
ranking member scott
for his opening statement and then
introduce our witnesses so they can
provide
testimony to the panel senator scott
well first i want to thank chair rosen
uh we we both come from tourism states
and we know the
uh the importance of making sure that we
have robust tourism
i remember uh being at i think it's
supposed to be the largest tourism
convention
or event uh supposedly in the world down
in
rio de janeiro brazil and las vegas
had an unbelievably beautiful um
space there and they they presented um
nevada really well
so it's a it's a great state and it's a
great place to take a vacation
i want to thank all of our witnesses for
being here today and sharing their
experiences
i'd like to thank somebody from florida
carol dover who's the president and ceo
of the florida restaurant and lodges
association for being with us today
i i finished a couple years ago as
governor of florida i worked
hand-in-hand with carol
tourism is a big deal in our state and
she's truly a champion for
our tourism industry in our state i want
to thank
chair cantwell and ranking member whip
wicker uh
for uh giving us the opportunity to do
this it's an honor to lead this
subcommittee with
uh senator rosen i look forward to the
important work we're gonna do to
drive our nation's tourism and trade
sectors to uh economic success
and as you heard from chair rosen some
of the states have really gotten hurt
because of what's happened with the
pandemic during our my time as governor
we put
we we invested actually quite a bit of
state money
and worked on growing uh tourism we went
from about 80 million tourists a year to
my last year 126 million tourists
but of course last year the state of
photos tourism like all other states is
down was down significantly
um we we shattered records and tourism
records and it creates a lot of jobs
and these business these visitors they
they support our small businesses
they fuel our job growth uh they help
increase our state and local investments
in the environment and transportation
and public safety and education
i said what happens in florida is people
come to visit and i'm sure the same
thing happens in nevada people come to
visit say this is a pretty nice place i
think i'll move here i'll build my
business here
so it's a real driver for economic
development i think in both of our
states
our state also has 15 seaports it's the
gateway to latin america
florida has become a hub for businesses
all across the nation for important
export
we try to move all all the business we
can out of california over to florida
uh the goods so goods that flow through
florida airports and seaports have grown
to 154 billion dollars a year
in order to do our focus on building
international trade relationships
um we uh in 2016 exports from florida
support and estimated 232 000 american
jobs so these are
the tourism is big jobs the the trade
jobs are big jobs with our ports we
invested in my eight years about 1.4
billion dollars
just in our ports i know that all this
pandemic has impacted every one of us
our families
um and all of us have tried to figure
out how to deal with this
uh keep everybody safe our family safe
our businesses safe and are
our employees safe i've heard from a lot
of small businesses around
my state that rely on the tourism
industry and have been absolutely
devastated by the pandemic
uh well i'm glad florida's open for
business our businesses are open our
schools are open
uh the uncertainty of when the industry
the tourism industry will reopen in
other states
uh in communities across the country has
clearly impacted those states and even
it's even impacted us
i know everybody's working incredibly
hard to keep their businesses going and
and and get back in business and and be
able to employ everybody again and
i hope that happens quickly uh as our
nation works to recover from the current
buyers
and get our economy back on track i'm
going to be doing everything i can with
senator rosen
to support the tourism industry in
florida and across the country
i'm also very focused on what happens in
puerto rico
the you know puerto rico was devastated
by hurricane maria and then they had the
earthquake and now covert 19
we worked hard to make sure there's good
aid for puerto rico's recovery
i've been working on a lot of a lot of
bills like senator rosen has
i have my uh bipartisan fly safe
canine cove detection act with center
cinema which directs the
tsa to conduct a feasibility study on
the use of canine units
which have been reportedly effective in
detecting covid and hopefully will
provide
an opportunity to make it people feel
safer flying
we got to get people back in the air for
all of our states
we also have a bipartisan bill fly safe
and healthy act with chair cantwell
to enable a temperature check pilot
program at airports and today i
introduced the careful resumption under
improved safety enhancement act
or the crews act with senator sullivan
and soon rubio to help our cruise
industry restart
and support the many businesses in our
communities that rely on the sex to the
success of the cruise industry i guess
you don't have a lot of cruises but you
have a lot of people
at uh they cruise up and down this las
vegas yeah
that's right and you've got you've got a
lot of water people cruise on
so it's been really frustrating now the
cruise industry has been waiting for
months for updated
guidance from the cdc and i think i
think it's it's wrong what's happened
they've got to we've got to give the
crews to the industry the root the terms
the rules
and they'll they'll reopen safely pete i
know that industry wants to do it safely
it's important job
created for us so i want to make sure
that happens we're going to do
everything we can and i look forward to
working
with all my all my colleagues to grow
tourism
not just in nevada not just in florida
but even in states
beautiful states like mississippi now
thank you senator scott and i would like
to now introduce uh here
in person our ranking member senator
thank you senator rosen to central scott
and sergeant scott i
share that sentiment with you because we
have a number of
tourism opportunities not not the least
of which is the national
civil rights trail and the national
blues trail
which more and more people are are
coming
to visit as well as our other more
traditional
tourism sites but thank you both for
holding this hearing today to your
industry perspectives
on the state of the travel and tourism
industry this is a great topic
for the new tourism trade and export
promotion
subcommittee i expect this committee
will be very busy
and i'll look forward to participating
the travel and tourism industry
is a key pillar of the american economy
before the kobe 19 pandemic this
industry supported roughly
16 million jobs and generated 1.1
trillion dollars in consumer spending
accounting for over 2.5 trillion
in total economic output kobe 19 has
devastated the industry perhaps more
than any other
economic sector in the united states
nearly 40 percent
of the total u.s jobs lost during the
pandemic
have been in leisure and hospitality
employment during the worst
point of this crisis unemployment in the
travel and tourism industry
reached over 50 percent more than
doubled the national unemployment rate
at the height of the great
depression congress has sought to
provide much-needed support
to help the industry recover the cares
act provided urgently needed
relief to travel and tourism businesses
in the form of grants
emergency loans and lines of credit the
fifth
coveted relief bill which passed in
december as part of the fy
21 appropriations act expanded the
industry's access
to many of these cares act relief
programs
more recently the american rescue plan
act
provided 750 million dollars for the
economic development administration
to help communities impacted by the loss
of travel and tourism
additionally the bill included a 28.6
billion dollar restaurant revitalization
fund
for restaurants modeled after the
bipartisan restaurants act
which i drafted with my friend senator
cinema
a member of this subcommittee the small
business administration has been
tasked with standing up the restaurant
fund and the sba may start
allocating grants very very soon
federal resources should help shore up
the travel and tourism sector but i
recognize the impacts of the pandemic
will be
long lasting hope our witnesses today
will update
the current status travel and tourism
industry
how the increasing availability of
co-editing vaccines
affects opportunities for recovery and
ways the public private sectors
can partner to help restore demand for
travel
as the public health situation improves
continues to improve it may take years
to restore travel and tourism
to its pre-pandemic levels but i hope
not
i'm hopeful that this subcommittee can
identify bipartisan opportunities
to help the sector heal and prosper much
sooner than that thank you madam chair
thank you thank you senator wicker and
uh
appreciate you being well chairman
chairman and ranking member
uh right now i'd like to welcome via
webex
senator cortez masto she's my partner in
representing nevada in the senate
she's a tireless advocate for travel and
tourism industry
and i'd like to welcome her to introduce
to the subcommittee
our witness from las vegas senator
cortez masto i turn it to you to
introduce
mr hill chair rosen thank you so much
ranking member scott
i really appreciate the opportunity uh
to join you today
uh it is great to be back in the
commerce committee that i enjoyed
serving on when i first
came to the senate this committee does
great work promoting our science
transportation technology sectors and
gives congress the ability to hold
hearings on important sectors
like this one on tourism as you know and
as you've stated tourism is vital to the
economic health
of our country i so appreciate you
bringing these experts to talk about the
importance
of the travel industry to nevada and to
the nation
as a whole all of these participants are
great partners and leaders in the travel
industry
which has been so hard hit by the cove
19 pandemic and our
tourism economy will need our full
support as the nation
recovers that's why i've been working in
a bipartisan way
on the hospitality and commerce job
recovery act with senator kramer
along with the bipartisan step act with
senators blunt klobuchar and the travel
act
that i'm about to introduce to help
elevate tourism at the department of
transportation
with that i appreciate the chance to be
here and introduce steve hill
steve has been an economic champion in
nevada for
many years since being named the ceo and
president of the las vegas convention
and visitors authority in 2018. steve
has done a great job
of creating more opportunities for
southern nevada to be
even more inviting place for our
visitors every year
from completion of the convention center
expansion
to the innovative people mover system
and now
weathering this health and economic
crisis steve has been a solid and steady
hand
in working to bring us out of this
critical challenge to our state
and local economy i appreciate his
partnership on many of the legislative
efforts that we have worked on as a
nevada delegation
and again i appreciate the committee
bringing his expertise
in for this hearing today thank you
thank you senator cortez master that was
a very kind
introduction and thank you chair rosen
ranking member scott for inviting me
to be here today i don't know
if it is appropriate to congratulate you
on the
formation of this subcommittee but it
seems like the right thing to do and so
i would like to congratulate you and
also
add the appreciation of our industry uh
for doing so we have
great supporters and senator cortez
masto and
senator rosen i know they represent
nevada well uh
in our tourism industry well in the
senate we
have uh really appreciated being able to
work with them
on much of the legislation that they've
sponsored on behalf of the
travel industry so thank you very much
as and i'm going to emphasize really
some of the things that you have already
said
our industry is central to the u.s
economy
it is a big part of the u.s economy
and it is critical to the recovery of
the u.s economy
as you mentioned the full strength our
industry
supports 16 million jobs in the united
states one in every nine jobs
it's one of the seven largest industries
uh in the country and it was certainly
the industry most affected by the
pandemic
when our industry is suffering it's
large enough it has a big enough impact
that it's felt throughout all of our
communities
it affects all of our suppliers and
service providers
and that's from the those that you think
of
initially from restaurants and local
attractions and also to cab drivers and
laundries and the construction workers
who
set up trade shows the list goes on
tourism is a significant driver
in every state but this is particularly
true in nevada
where as senator rosen mentioned
hospitality supports one in four nevada
jobs
two and a half times the national
average
the las vegas convention and visitors
authority is
a unique organization and that we are
the only entity in a major city
in the united states to serve as both
the destination marketing organization
as well as the convention and visitors
bureau
as with many convention centers
throughout the country
our mission certainly expanded over the
last year
and it includes doing what we could to
help the community respond to the
pandemic
we're the state's largest coveted test
center we are currently the state's
largest vaccine site
we are a fema distribution center we
provided space for courtrooms for
eviction assistance
we have space in the community needed
space and we were
happy and proud to be a part of all of
those efforts
we recently purchased the las vegas
monorail system after it was forced
to close due to the pandemic we needed
to preserve this important
transportation system
and through the last year we finished
the construction of our 1.4 million
square foot expansion
and you may have seen last week
showcased on the first commercial
application of
elon musk the boring company's
innovative transportation system which
now
runs underneath the campus of our
convention center
we are looking forward to both recovery
and
return to prosperity and we do hope to
be able to speed that up
people in this industry need that they
need their jobs back
our state and local governments need
this industry to recover to generate the
tax revenue they count on
to provide services our customers need
to travel frankly
they need to see their family and
friends they haven't seen in the last
year
they need to meet a potential new
customer
to experience a new culture or frankly
just to set aside
what's happened over the last year and
get away for a few days
the first step part of recovery as you
all mentioned
will be moving beyond the health crisis
and
continuing the vaccination process is
the key to making that happen
we need to get to the point now where
socially distancing is no longer
necessary
like many destinations las vegas doesn't
work well
without a crowd and we are optimistic
that we are on the cusp of that we think
that
has the ability to happen but once
beyond the health crisis our industry
will be faced with a situation that is
roughly equivalent
to the depths of the great recession
that will be where we are
once we get past the health crisis and
are just simply dealing with the
economic
fallout as a result
domestic and leisure travel will recover
first
and it's already doing so we're seeing
strength there
but business travel and international
travel
will certainly take longer the oecd
receives a good portion of our funding
through a fixed percentage of room tax
it's a good indicator
of the health of our tourism and
hospitality industry
typically we would receive about 300
million dollars a year
in our current fiscal year which ends in
june we will receive about 100
so about a third of our normal revenue
we are projecting next year that we will
receive about 70
of our normal room tax revenue so
we will we will show improvement but
it's only about halfway
to where we need to be over the next 12
months
because the lbcv is involved in a number
of ways i'll just mention the
transportation and transportation
infrastructure
in all forms will be a key to recovering
fully and
having real growth from them i was
honored to serve on the
national advisory committee on travel
and tourism infrastructure a few years
ago
the report we issued then was relatively
brief and contained a focused
set of recommendations key
recommendation was to create a national
travel infrastructure strategy
we have a national freight plan but we
do not have a full national travel plan
corridors of regional significance need
to be a focus
of that strategy in the west and in
nevada our state
i-15 is one such corridor it affects
states that
runs directly through from california to
montana
as well as neighboring states such as
wyoming and colorado
and the importance of that corridor can
be seen in the makeup of this committee
where half of this committee represents
states
affected by i-15 so
we look forward to working with you on
chair rosen on
the formation of the 915 caucus in
congress and we thank you for your help
with that and again i would like to
thank
you ranking member scott all the members
of the committee
for the opportunity to be before you
here today
thank you for all you have done and all
you will do
for the travel industry
is jorge perez regional portfolio
president
at mgm resorts international mr perez
oversees the strategic
direction for eight of mgm's resorts
properties
mr perez is an industry veteran with 25
years of experience in the hospitality
industry mr perez i recognize you for
your opening remarks
good afternoon thank you chairwoman
rosen chairwoman conwell
ranking member scott and ranking member
wicker and members of the subcommittee
as you mentioned my name is jorge perez
and i'm the regional portfolio president
i oversee the eight regional domestic
properties
for mgm resorts outside of las vegas and
i appreciate the opportunity
to provide testimony on behalf of our
organization
and to share some of our experiences
during this incredibly challenging year
mgm resorts international is a global
entertainment company with 29
unique hotels and venue destinations
across
eight states and macau last year
was one of the most difficult years ever
faced by our industry
our company and by our employees
ngm first felt the impacts of the
pandemic at our properties in macau
which closed in february 2020 and
shortly thereafter in march 2020
our regional properties was were closed
and then eventually
our las vegas properties leaving the
strip
closed for the very first time in its
history
like many we faced a number of difficult
decisions including having the furlough
a significant portion of our workforce
but during this time of great hardship
our company and team members sought ways
to demonstrate
care and compassion for one another
and for the most impacted in our
communities we provided extended health
benefits
for our employees and our families we
disbursed over 15 and a half million
dollars to help employees during the
pandemic via our employee emergency
grant fund
and within days of shutting down we
donated hundreds of thousands of meals
to people in need mgm also helped to
procure much needed ppe for our medical
professionals including mast
gowns and gloves we continue to focus on
our commitment
to the communities that have welcomed us
to give generosity to our neighbors and
embody our core value of embracing
humanity every day
while it has been a year of hardship it
has also been a year of innovation and
change
when we reopen our properties we
drastically overhauled our operations
mgm implemented comprehensive protocols
via our seven-point health and safety
plan
which included installation of plexi
plexi glass dividers hand washing
stations across our resorts
digital innovations including touchless
menus in our restaurants and our bars
the ability for our guests to check in
utilizing a mobile phone
enhanced hvac protocols temperature
testing for team members and our guests
and on-site rapid kobe 19 tests for our
events
just to name a few as the world strives
to return normal
we appreciate the continued leadership
and support of the federal government
the coronavirus relief bills passed by
congress of
so many around the country our full loan
employees who extended unemployment
benefits
our small business partners through the
paycheck protection program
and mgm for the employee retention tax
credit
which helped provide extended health
benefits for our employees and their
families
now withstanding these efforts the
country's travel and tourism industries
and our workers have been hit
disproportionately hard
nationwide as mentioned earlier travel
spending was down 500 billion costing
the us economy about 1.1 trillion
dollars
at the current pace the travel industry
is not expected to fully recover until
2025 but we are hopeful the recovery
will arrive much sooner there are key
political initiatives that can help our
industry achieve a speedy recovery
and the nearly 16 million american
workers that employed before the
pandemic
one of the biggest policy priorities for
the traveling tourism industry is the
bipartisan legislation introduced by
senator
catherine cortes masto and senator kevin
kramer
the hospitality and commerce job
recovery act of 2021
which provides various tax credits to
simulate our industry
additionally would assist the convention
and trade show sector
which disproportionately impacted which
was disproportionately impacted
and is so crucial to the industry's
recovery
we also welcome the safe and
science-based easing
of government restrictions which will
permit us to bring back more of our
world-renowned amenities
to a greater number of guests allowing
us to bring back more our employees
at amgm we understand the need to remain
diligent
and maintain our focus on the well-being
of our employees and our guests
vaccination is critically important tool
in helping to end the pandemic and
accelerate our communities economic
recovery
we are committed to doing anything we
can to help get as many people
vaccinated
as quickly as possible by removing
barriers to access
and bringing vaccination clinics
directly to our employees
it has been a difficult year but there
is great reason
for cautious optimism and we're starting
to see signs of recovery
we at mgm resorts await the ability to
welcome and entertain the world
without restriction and to help our
guests celebrate life
to its fullest thank you for the
opportunity to present testimony today
thank you mr perez testifying next
is tori emerson barnes executive vice
president of public affairs and policy
at the u.s
travel association ms barnes leads the
u.s
travel association's government
relations policy development
communications marketing and research
teams
ms barnes is here with us today in
person and i recognize you for your
opening remarks
thank you chair rosen a ranking member
scott and members of the subcommittee
good afternoon
i'm tori emerson barnes executive vice
president of public affairs and policy
for the u.s travel association
we're the only association that
represents all sectors of the travel
industry
and i'm very happy to be here in person
and grateful for the leadership that
you're putting forward here today
before the pandemic 1.1 trillion dollars
in travel spending generated 2.6
trillion dollar economic
impact and supported 16 million american
jobs
this came to a halt at the onset of the
pandemic
last year travel spending fell 42
costing the economy 500 billion dollars
in lost travel spend
international inbound visitation
declined 76 percent
and business travel spending fell 70
percent
additionally 5.6 million travel
supported jobs were lost
accounting for 65 percent of all jobs
lost to the pandemic
at the state level nevada florida and
washington state suffered travel
spending declines of more than 40
percent
travel spending fell 26 in mississippi
currently the travel industry is
expected to take five years
to recover from this crisis and that's
far too long
to wait while we expect domestic leisure
travel to recover more quickly
a full rebound is not certain and it
won't make up for losses in other
segments
professional meetings and events which
are the travel industry's largest
generator of
spending revenue are still restricted in
many states
this sector is protect projected to take
four years to recover
and with our borders still closed to
much of the world international
travel to the u.s will take as many as
five years to return to pre-pandemic
levels
with the uncertainty around reopening it
could be even longer
u.s travel has identified four key
priorities to restore travel demand
accelerate rehiring and shorten the
recovery timeline
first we must safely and quickly reopen
international travel
we have the right protections in place
to safely reopen
but we don't have clear public health
benchmarks or a definitive timeline to
return
to open our borders u.s travel has urged
the biden administration to develop by
this may
a road map and a timeline for lifting
entry restrictions with the goal of
reopening international
travel by july we can start by
establishing public health corridors
between the u.s and other low-risk
countries such as the united kingdom
second the cdc should approve clear
guidance that states and localities
can use to lift restrictions and safely
restart professional meetings and events
nearly all sectors of the economy have
clear guidelines to allow them to reopen
amid the pandemic
business meetings are distinct from
other mass gatherings due to the level
of control that can be implemented
and should not remain closed while the
rest of the economy is given the green
light to reopen
third congress should enact the
hospitality and commerce jobs recovery
act
to spur demand and accelerate rehiring
this bill would increase travel demand
among low to middle income families by
providing
targeted and temporary refundable tax
credits to travel
while also helping to boost demand
spending and rehiring
the bill would also provide refundable
tax credits to encourage professional
meetings and events to restart
further oxford economics estimates
estimates that enacting this bill would
shorten the recovery timeline from five
years to just three
while creating an incremental 1.5
million jobs
and generating nearly 600 billion
dollars in spending
fourth congress should provide temporary
emergency funding for brand usa
america's destination marketing
organization
over the last seven years brand usa's
marketing efforts have generated a 26 to
one
return on investment for the u.s economy
however the drastic decline in sfv
collections due to international travel
restrictions
combined with scarce private sector
contributions
during the economic crisis have
decimated the program's funding
if brand usa is unable to continue its
important work
international travel recovery will be
severely limited
specific policies can also be
implemented to improve the industry's
long-term competitiveness and ensure
that we come back
stronger than ever these policies
include passing the visit america act
which senator sullivan
introduced last year to elevate travel
leadership in the federal government
this would strengthen the commerce
department's role in coordinating
federal travel policies
and set consistent national goals and
strategies to boost travel exports
finally investing in our country's
infrastructure will help facilitate
travel
and better prepare us to welcome back
visitors from around the world
by prioritizing infrastructure
investments now
the u.s can emerge from the pandemic and
rebuild the travel industry with
stronger
more connected systems than ever before
we need the federal government to enact
the right policies to ensure
all sectors of travel can recover as
quickly as possible
and any delay in reopening any segment
will only hurt our economy further thank
you again for inviting the travel
industry to testify today
uh on such a devastating economic impact
of the of the pandemic and i welcome
your questions
thank you thank you miss barnes
our final witness is carol dover
president and ceo of the florida
restaurant and lodging association
ms dover also serves as a member of
several boards
including the board of directors for the
national restaurant association
council of state restaurant associations
and international society of hotel
association
executives ms dover i recognize you via
webex for your opening remarks
thank you chair cantwell ranking member
wicker
and subcommittee chair rosen and ranking
member scott
and other distinguished members for the
opportunity to be
here to represent florida's hospitality
industry
for more than 26 years i have led the
florida restaurant and lodging
association
frla which represents over 10 000
members
from the biggest names in hotels
restaurants
theme parks to small independent
operators and suppliers
hospitality and tourism is the largest
industry in florida and it is the
economic engine of our state
in 2019 a record setting 131 million
visitors added nearly 97 billion dollars
to florida's economy
tourism was florida's largest employer
with over 1.5 million
employees before covid our nearly
112 billion dollar hospitality industry
was booming with hundreds of new hotels
thousands of new restaurants and we were
on track to set new records
when covet hit we were shell-shocked
more than 62 percent of florida's
hospitality employees were furloughed or
laid off
hotels restaurants bars cruise lines
theme parks shut down
air travel stopped business conferences
and large events were canceled
the frla went into overdrive to help our
members survive
interpreting executive orders and
serving as an information clearinghouse
we helped our workers get ppe and other
coded supplies
we were heavily engaged with our state
and federal leaders
and are grateful for the support of
senator scott
and rubio we were blessed to work
closely with governor desantis by
assisting to create guidelines
and safety protocols to get our industry
reopened
there were many creative solutions that
our industry embarked upon from
opening groceronds to putting up dining
tables in parking lots
alcohol to go became a critical revenue
source for restaurants
and we were working now with the florida
legislature to try to make that
permanent
we've worked with our national
association partners on federal relief
packages
that have been critical to our survival
our industry is also facing historic
workforce challenges
although we are allowed to operate at
100 capacity in florida
we can't find staff simply put
we're competing with state and federal
unemployment benefits
workers tell us that they make too much
money on unemployment to return to work
so businesses are forced to limit
capacity shorten their hours
without adequate staff to serve guests
florida is
open for business but we're desperate
for workers
covid has decimated the u.s tourism
industry which suffered more than 500
billion dollars in pandemic
related losses half of the u.s hotel
rooms are projected to remain empty this
year
and hotel employment will not come back
until at least
2023 business travel the single largest
source of hotel revenue will remain down
85
and it's going to take years to recover
thousands of hotels have closed
and have been foreclosed florida had the
second
highest hotel job loss in the nation
behind california
restaurants have also been shattered
from nationwide shutdowns to ban on
indoor dining to misleading claims
about the safety of restaurants 2020
ended with total sales that were 240
billion dollars
less than projections nationally more
than 8 million restaurant employees were
laid off
or furloughed and 600 thousand of them
were in florida
more than a hundred and ten thousand
restaurants closed
permanently including over ten thousand
of those in florida
nationally the restaurant industry lost
nearly
2.5 million jobs we are hopeful
that ppp tax credits and the recently
passed
restaurant revitalization fund have been
huge victories
the rrf will provide 28.6 billion
dollars in grants for restaurants
who desperately need it thank you
ranking member wicker
and committee member cinema for your
bipartisan work
in creating the restaurant act to keep
us open
travel tourism and the hospitality
industries
have faced the worst years in history in
florida we understand emergencies
but there was no playbook for covid19
and nothing has ever tested us like this
we love creating memorable experiences
for guests that keep coming back
but we need for them to be able to come
back international visitors
cruises business travel we are working
to rebuild this industry that we
love so dearly we are hospitality strong
but we have no problem asking for your
help
and we still desperately need your
support as we rebuild
thank you chair and i'll be happy to
take any questions that you may have
well thank you so much for your opening
remarks and i really appreciate
everyone's thoughtful opening remarks
because senator scott and i believe
that we must get americans traveling
again
and so as we've discussed several times
travel and tourism of course are the
lifeblood of nevada's economy
culvert 19 like you have all have said
has taken a toll
on our workers across this nation on our
businesses and on our communities
but with more americans getting
vaccinated and the cdc giving the green
light
for safe travel there is a light at the
end of the tunnel
but to fully recover and bring back the
jobs lost
the industry we must bring it back to
pre-pandemic levels we need to get
americans
and the world traveling again that means
making sure that people from across the
country
and across the globe know that our
tourism destinations well they are
open for business so mr perez
can you talk about the importance of out
of state
and international travelers to mgm
success and that of its workforce and i
would say
all of our hotels and the success of its
workforce please
share um let me let me start off first
with the regional properties um
you know we're in seven different states
uh some in the northeast
mid-atlantic and and down senator
wicker's uh nick of the woods down in uh
mississippi
um the for those
for those properties most of our
business comes from
an hour's drive and we were a bit more
insulated um barring the closure
obviously but we were a bit more
insulated
um in las vegas because the barriers of
travel
were just easier you can jump in your
car and not have to deal with airfare
and that sort of thing um las vegas
um and and i'll parallel that too with
we do have two
semi-destination resorts one of which is
in biloxi mississippi
um that property also was hampered more
as compared to the other seven as an
example it behaved a little bit more
like las vegas
and it also brought out in atlantic city
had similar um characteristics to
recovery
in las vegas but nowhere near as
devastating um
it's your point in and you've heard the
testimony from from the panelists
um the getting getting customers
comfortable with air travel primarily
is paramount and um and it's to take
some time to get international travel
to come back in earnest particularly in
las vegas which is vitally important
we know those customers stay longer um
they enjoy our restaurants they enjoy
our casinos
they enjoy our shows they've spent quite
a bit on retail
and they're vitally important to the
embattled and las vegas economy so
um anything that we can do certainly to
reduce those barriers would be
incredibly helpful especially for las
vegas
thank you mr hill i'd like to ask you a
similar question
but really about our conventions we know
that conventions
business travel is the lifeblood of not
just
las vegas but so many other cities
across the country
so uh how do you feel about uh what can
we do to bring that ecotourism back what
do we need
and its importance to our communities
well thank you chair rosen uh i
iranian remember scott earlier mentioned
the
connection between tourism and economic
development and
i would just add that really tourism
is economic development too and
it brings money in from outside of our
state
into our state it creates those
26 percent of the jobs in nevada
it is a it is the economic
engine for our state and domestic and
international
tourists are what make that possible
that you know a year ago or a little
longer ago
when we were trying to get from 87
room occupancy 90 percent
that concept seemed maybe not as
important as
what we went through when we shut down
for 10 weeks
and didn't have any visitors in nevada
and as you pointed out suffered the
worst
unemployment rate of any state in
history
during that period of time so it is our
domestic and international
travelers are what make this state go
and we need to do everything we can to
allow them to return and i know everyone
is
from a meetings and convention
perspective
we are excited to have i think the first
large trade show in the united states
returning to our convention center
in early june world country by informa
the publicly traded firm that is a
one of the biggest customers of las
vegas uh it's a
show that typically has 50 60 000
attendees
we don't think it will be that size but
it will be
a major show and we look forward not
only to that show returning
but it's serving as
evidence and an example of how to do
this right
and we're excited about that
international visitation is a big
component
of visitation both from a business
traveler standpoint as well as a leisure
traveler
we enjoy about 15 percent in a normal
year
visitation from our international fans
and that has been almost completely
shut down and has not really started to
recover at this point
and as miss barnes mentioned
working to get those back
those visitors back working on a method
so that they can have confidence in
their travel plans
and be able to confidently make those
trips
we think is critically important
thank you and now recognize ranking
member scott
thank you chair rosen i want to thank
each of the witnesses for your testimony
um ms dover in your written testimony
you state that the travel and tourism
industry is facing historic labor
shortages
which could significantly restrict the
industry from recovering from this
severe downturn
can you share the reasons behind this
would you be able to
give you some examples from your members
as well as what they've done to mitigate
this issue uh and just go ahead and talk
about some of the challenges your
members are facing
with regard to labor shortages
yes thank you very much senator scott so
as i stated in my other statement that
we're
in competition with our unemployment
system
so many people are making more money
staying home
and we're having a really tough time
getting people to even want to apply for
jobs
we've been hosting job fairs some of our
members are even offering bonuses
and people are still not showing up to
apply for the jobs
just a couple of examples senator that
we're hearing from our members i have a
member yesterday who's telling me that
they haven't had their garbage picked up
in
almost a week and and so this is bigger
than just
the hotel and restaurant industry the
waste management industry they don't
have drivers
we got notice from our food distribute
uh distribution companies and
our beverage companies that they may not
be receiving their products in a timely
manner because
they too don't have enough drivers
applying for jobs so
one of the things that we are in hopes
is that we can
find between both state and federal
clearly unemployment is important for
many people but there are so many jobs
available right now
that if we could go back to a system
where you used to have to show
that you had applied and been turned
down for several jobs three jobs i
believe is what it was in florida
that um if we could reverse some of
those
mandates then i believe that we could
begin to see people
want to go back to work so we are
desperate
and anything that you all can do in
congress to help us
relieve this burden i hear from my
colleagues all across the country that
this is not just a florida issue that
it's everywhere
so thank you for for asking and allowing
me the opportunity to talk to you about
our
very uh critical labor shortage so
missed over so if somebody
if an employer tells an employee that
they have a job openings in my
understanding nationwide we have 7.4
million job openings
if an employer says they have a job
opening does the employee
be is are they able to continue on
unemployment or do they
are they required to come back to work
well they're not required senator my
understanding to come back to work
they can make the decision and what
we're trying to
also do education to many of the people
who are not coming back to work is to
remind
them that these jobs will not be
available forever
i mean we've all you've heard us all
today on the panel talk about the need
to rebound and we will rebound this is
we're a resilient country and we will
rebound
but one day these jobs that people are
turning down
won't be available anymore so we're
reminding people to
take these jobs while they're available
unemployment in florida is already down
to
a little over four percent so it's not
long before
you know we're gonna be in a very low
unemployment
and nearly an unemployable so hopefully
we can get people to
see that we have great jobs available
florida is the tourism mecca we and we
have
just hopefully people will see the
importance of coming back to work
thank you mr orton um ms barnes we've
seen the cruise industry as stand still
under the current cdc restrictions with
no timeline in place for return what
impact
has this had not only on the cruise
industry but throughout the travel and
tourism industries
thank you for the question um you know
we very much
are supportive of the legislation that
you and senator uh sullivan introduced
today along with senator rubio
um because we really do think that the
entire industry needs to have uh clear
guidelines on how to reopen
uh with uh of the timeline and a date
certain uh to do so
uh and and really we are normally uh
used to welcoming over
13 million uh travelers via cruise ship
annually uh to the united states and the
impact that that has on
ports and destinations throughout the
country uh restaurants
attractions uh folks that are uh being
able to
to sell um uh
gifts for their families uh at those
ports and in those cities
uh so the impact really has been quite
significant
and we really believe that every segment
of the industry
should be able again to reopen uh and
that it isn't fair uh not to have
clear guidelines so uh we hope that the
the
cdc uh will be able to put forward uh
clear guidelines in the in the immediate
term because the economic consequences
really are significant not only to
florida but to to the
other countries like alaska louisiana
california washington and other states
across the country thank you thank you
joe rosen
thank you senator scott i'd like to next
recognize via webex senator
klobuchar thank you very much
uh chair rosen and uh thank you as well
to
uh senator scott um and i'm really
excited to hear from our witnesses today
i know this has been such a tough time
for tourism but
having this hearing couldn't be more
timely um
i have long been involved in this issue
from the time that i had
the job of chairing the tourism
subcommittee in commerce
um proud of the work that we've done
together with some of the witnesses on
brand usa
and the work that you're doing today and
i guess i'd start there because i know
that
um senator rosen asked a question and
talked about the loss at least of
international travel
on the mgm resorts and also really
everywhere in the country which is part
of the reason we were so proud of the
work we've done
on brand usa which finally allowed us to
have an even playing field when it came
to
promoting our own country this has been
a real gut punch for the tourism
industry
obviously uh we had to shut down the
borders for
international tourists but as we see
this as we call it in
on lake superior the lighthouse on the
horizon as opposed to light at the end
of the tunnel
um with the vaccine and what's happening
um
ms barnes in your testimony you
highlight that if international travel
is not reopened soon a total of 1.1
million american jobs
and 262 billion in spending will be lost
by the end of 2021
and that temporary emergency funding for
brand usa is needed uh can you talk
about what resources you think
are needed sure thank you senator for
your um
question and for your tremendous
leadership as the chair of the
travel and tourism caucus in the senate
uh we are very grateful for your
leadership uh
in particular as we sought to
reauthorize brand usa
uh back in late 2019 which feels like a
decade ago
except you must admit we were smart to
do it early
we got it done a year early thanks to
senator blunt and other events
yes great both of you thank you um so as
i noted
uh international travels declined by 76
percent
uh and right now we're looking at a
five-year time horizon for recovery
but we know that we can shorten that
timeline uh and
just in in the losses for 2021
uh if we are able to reopen
international travel by july
um that can stimulate 40 of the the
expected
expected losses this year so we really
need brand usa
uh that is currently uh having a funding
challenge because of
um the lack of international travel
usually the esta fe
uh is coming in in a robust fashion and
capped at 100 million which goes to
brand usa but
because that money isn't coming in
because the international borders are
closed
we really need an emergency funding
mechanism uh what we think is about 250
million dollars
in an appropriation usually the 100
million that comes in on international
fees is matched by the private sector
but unfortunately due to the decimation
of the private sector right now
those matching funds are are unlikely to
be captured so
again if if the appropriations uh
committee could could put forward 250
million
we think they'll be able to do their
work to bring back international
travelers
and make sure that that 26 to 1 return
on investment is uh
is provided and i'll just note since we
were talking about exports that
in 2019 the tourism industry provided a
59 billion dollar
export for the for the country so it
really is
uh important beyond uh just domestic
funding
very good and then another bill uh that
senator blunt and i have
introduced the protecting tourism in the
united states act
directs the commerce department uh in
consultation with the u.s
travel and tourism board and key federal
agencies to develop a plan
uh to help the tourism industry recover
simply because
you know i think that as things are
getting a little better where this their
their ramp up is going to be slower by
virtue of the nature
of the customers here and where they
come from and how they can travel
than other industries and i guess i'll
turn to
you on to you with us mr perez and by
the way
um i'm also want to mention the great
leadership of
uh chair rosen as well as senator cortez
masto
on these issues um with nevada
but one report found that in 2020 more
than 670 000 hotel industry jobs
and in your testimony you know that mgm
resorts had to furlough
60 000 employees as a result of the
pandemic
can you speak to how long the hotel
industry can sustain itself on the
current federal
economic relief particularly regarding
your workforce thank you very much
senator for the question
um look the
employees are coming back uh not only
in las vegas but also for our regional
properties
but they're doing so when the customers
have started to come back
what we've seen clearly as vaccinations
um shots and arms um are becoming more
pervasive
things have turned around relatively
quickly the question for us is how
sustainable
is that um because it happened as you
know we were
uh leaving the winter if you will
entering better weather
um and um
along with the stimulus so there's a
little there's a little bit of noise
um but uh the
the the way this is this is um
and i apologize um uh
the i apologize
can you can you repeat the question for
a second i'm sorry well no it was just
it's okay because i'm i'm probably out
of time
and my colleagues are probably black but
you forgot the question
no it was just basically about it was
mostly about how long the hotel industry
can sustain itself
yeah so and and what i'll say i'll just
end it really
really quickly um and it right now it is
a bit of challenge
um particularly in las vegas and a few
of our other regional properties to find
labor
uh for the uh for the reasons mentioned
earlier
and um the the
you know as our customers return um we
feel that
with time we can get our employees back
and do this in the right form
in right fashion so um but it's it's a
process
it's a process very good and we hope
you're working as well with carlson
companies in minnesota
uh we have a we're proud of the work
they're doing thank you
thank you senator klobuchar next i'd
like to like to recognize
in person senator sullivan thank you
madam chair and i really appreciate this
committee i think it's exciting i think
it's going to be an important committee
very bipartisan
all these issues and i'm looking forward
to
year and senator scott's uh leadership
on this
um miss barnes i wanted to ask you you
mentioned my
visit america act which is very
bipartisan with senator schatz and
senator king uh one thing it would do it
would in a stat it would establish an
assistant secretary
of commerce for travel and tourism is
you and i have discussed
many countries have cabinet officials
in charge of tourism we don't even have
an assistant secretary now i'm not a big
government guy but as you know when
you're in
in in the debates within the federal
agencies you need
someone senate confirmed to
uh stand up for this huge part of our
economy
which goes across so many states can you
share with me a little bit of your
perspective of the importance of this
act it passed out of this committee
very strongly every senator but one
voted for it and we're gonna try and
move it again quickly this year
yes thank you for your question and and
for your leadership on on this
issue um you're right we're the only one
of the top 30
global destinations that doesn't have a
cabinet level
uh uh person and or an arm that actually
goes out and promotes travel that's why
we have brand usa so
uh we believe very much that the
leadership is needed um we've been very
pleased with secretary raimondo's um
interest in how important travel and
tourism is to the
industry but obviously she has many
things to to focus on so we couldn't
agree with you more
um that we'd like to see your bill
introduced uh again quickly and passed
and we've already also raised with the
secretary
the importance of elevating this
position so uh
hopeful that we will will be able to
move it forward
um it's also something that we've talked
to the travel and tourism advisory board
at the national travel tourism office
at the department of commerce about and
believe that
that with this type of leadership to to
really be able to draw that interagency
group together
um that we can um set that national
strategy to reopen
um not only domestic travel but bring
back international travel
bring back meetings and events we need
the whole of the industry
um focused upon and having a cabinet
level position would absolutely help do
that
great thank you my next question is for
you
and miss dover i i want to talk a little
bit about the cruise ship industry and
and you know a lot of times the industry
gets attacked for certain issues but
what i really want to talk about
is how important this industry
is to small businesses whether in
florida or
in alaska and um if you can give us a
sense on that but also
uh miss barnes i saw that um the u.s
travel association
recently called for the cdc to end its
ban on cruise ship travel
in america that's uh what our bill
senator scott
and my bill the cruz act that we
introduced today
would do and and they need the guidance
and look the cdc
does a good job on the science they've
had a tough year
an important agency my state has worked
hard
dealing with the health issues we've
been the number one state in the country
throughout the pandemic in terms of
testing per capita
in terms of the vaccination rates per
capita we're proud of that in alaska
fortunately one of the lowest death
rates per capita
but my state's economy is getting
crushed
oil and gas no